c'est le ministre sur le Président mes
chers collègues suite à la tuerie de
Toulouse de mars 2012 de nombreuses
propositions avaient été faites par
chacun des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle afin que nous n'ayons pas
à revivre de tels événements
parmi ces propositions beaucoup
portaient sur l'influence grandissante
d'Internet dans le développement des
groupes terroristes le profil de Mohamed
Merah qui filmait ses crimes pour les
publier sur le net celui des terroristes
de Boston confirment et de loin cette
analyse ainsi l'utilisation des moyens
internet permet aujourd'hui à ces
groupuscules de recruter des djihadistes
improvisés mais aussi de diffuser leur
propagande parmi les réseaux sociaux les
plus utilisés les plus accessibles dont
Twitter Facebook YouTube et bien
d'autres faut-il rappeler d'ailleurs
tout le monde le sait que certains
magazines en ligne vont jusqu'à
illustrer la fabrication d'explosifs à
ce sujet l'article premier de la loi du
21 décembre 2012 a prévu de prolonger
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2015 l'accès
préventif des services chargés de la
lutte contre le terrorisme aux données
techniques recueillies dans les
communications électroniques ou lors de
l'accès à Internet
ce dispositif que la précédente majorité
avait autorisé en 2006 et qui devait
s'achever en 2012 fin 2012 a donc été
renouvelé c'est une excellente chose
pourtant il faut bien admettre que dans
ce domaine la lutte contre le terrorisme
est loin d'être abouti tant il reste
d'obstacle à franchir du fait notamment
de la difficulté technique de maîtriser
les flux internets ainsi j'aimerais
savoir Monsieur le Ministre quelles sont
aujourd'hui les orientations du
gouvernement quant à la politique a mené
en ce qui concerne le contrôle de
certains réseaux Internet par les
groupuscules terroristes quels moyens
pourrait être mis en oeuvre pour limiter
leur action et qu'est-ce qui nous
empêche aujourd'hui d'approfondir cette
question y a-t-il des moyens humains à
mettre en complément y a-t-il des moyens
techniques à mettre en complément ces
interrogations sont d'autant plus
importantes qu'Internet présente un
risque accru dans la radicalisation des
individus d'abord en accentuant le
relâchement de leur propre lien sociaux
individuels et c'est à mon avis
gravissime ensuite on leur fournissant
les moyens d'agir et enfin en glorifiant
leur crime
merci monsieur le ministre le président
monsieur le sénateur André Richard oui
là aussi vous l'avez souligné dans ce
débat les uns et les autres Internet est
devenu avec vecteur de propagande de
radicalisation et de recrutement pour la
mouvance terroriste et Internet fait
l'objet d'une surveillance vigilante de
la dessérie afin d'y détecter les
activités de la mouvance terroriste la
loi vous l'avez souligné prévoit
plusieurs moyens destinés à lutter
contre l'usage d'Internet et les réseaux
de communication électroniques à des
fins terroristes il y a des moyens
d'enquête aussi qui sont utilisés la loi
de 2012 renforce l'arsenal juridique
dans la lutte contre la propagande
terroriste sur internet mais il nous
faut sans cesse nous adapter parce que
le terrorisme a souvent un train
d'avance par rapport à la loi et au
moyen légaux de l'État je l'ai souligner
il y a un instant d'autres évolutions du
cadre juridique de la contre le cyber
terrorisme seront sans aucun doute
nécessaire à l'avenir et ils devront
compléter notre arsenal juridique comme
je m'étais engagé un travail
interministériel est en cours avec les
ministères de la Justice des finances de
l'économie numérique pour adapter notre
droit qui doit évoluer nos moyens
investigations mais aussi nos
organisations et méthodes de travail aux
enjeux de la cybercriminalité ça ne
concerne pas d'ailleurs que le
terrorisme elles devront bien sûr
concilier l'efficacité de la prévention
et le respect des libertés individuelles
elle nous oblige aussi à une très grande
coopération européenne et là je crois
que il y a les bases d'un accord entre
les pays de l'Union elle nous oblige à
un dialogue avec nos amis américains qui
sur ces questions là ne nous suivent pas
toujours du fait de leur amendement
numéro un et sur le contrôle de
l'Internet il me semble que c'est un des
principaux enjeux des prochains mois
dans les discussions avec nos
partenaires
monsieur André Richard si vous le
souhaitez
oui pour remercier Monsieur ministre de
cette réponse je voudrais naturellement
dire que face à la menace terroriste
actuelle cette lutte contre le
terrorisme doit être érigé en véritable
priorité nationale et à cet égard à cet
égard tout ce qui peut être fait pour
améliorer notre efficacité en ce qui
concerne le contrôle des flux internet
doit être fait je pense que dans le
cadre de cette priorité nationale des
moyens particuliers doivent être
affectés en la matière et je vous
remercie de bien vouloir le prendre en
compte merci